millions of people live every day with
severe pain it doesn't matter if you
start hurting today or if you're dealing
with an injury from 30 years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his gentle method of chiropractic care
can help
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents false injuries we think
nothing about
but they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife faye
oh it's been probably now eight months
ago she started developing
tiredness fatigue she had headaches she
had
nausea started getting some adjustments
and probably after about three four
weeks she started feeling a little bit
better
noticeably so and in about two months
magically so to speak she was fine
tanuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients uh
young children
um people who've been in bad car
accidents bad falls maybe we've even had
surgery before
up to 80 90 year old men and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two day work up day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests checking every range of
motion of their spine orthopedic
neurological test posture
and then we're going to take digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best
type of films in our field i'm going to
study those i'm going to study the notes
so day two we're going to sit down and
i'm going to go over the findings and
listen if i can't help someone i'm going
to let them know and i'm going to get
them to the right doc if i can help
i'm very straightforward how long is it
going to take what's it going to cost
what's my insurance do or not do
because if you're anything like me you
don't want financial surprises and we're
going to get to work
and start getting some relief as soon as
possible my life's changed immensely
i'm pain-free where i used to have
shoulder neck pain wasn't able to lift
my arms
brush my own hair it's almost like a
relief
when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's it's amazing
you heard dr devin talk about the
importance of the exam and digital
x-rays well
write down the number on your screen
because the first 20 callers
will only pay 37 for both
normally it's 180 dollars call 702
566 hope or 702-566-4673
you can also get more information at
drdevin.com
las vegas now we'll be right back